don't become accustomed to being treated
like [ __ ]
[Music]
these days senators don't even have to
show up to work to filibuster any
senator can send an email and if 60
other senators don't feel like
challenging it that's enough to
filibuster a bill and the senator
doesn't even have to tell the american
people why
and i think they should if you're
getting paid by my tax dollars to not
make lynching illegal i want you to have
to stand up there and say why and i want
you to be wearing really pointy
uncomfortable shoes when you do it also
i'm sure every speech would start out
with some pretty language about states
rights or something but there is no way
a racist can talk that long without
saying something racist and i want to
see it i think it would be funny
so
now you're thinking okay just because
the filibuster started out racist and
then was only used to be racist for a
long time that doesn't mean it's racist
now right
oh you sweet summer child it's true that
these days the filibuster is used for a
wider variety of issues but any guesses
on when republicans set the record for
doing the most filibusters
can you guess who was in office
i'll give you one more guess
that's right so the filibuster is like
when you see a white person buying brown
makeup on halloween
technically they could be using it for
anything but they're probably going to
do a racism so that's how we got to
where we are now thanks in large part to
the filibuster we are still struggling
with black people's voting rights don't
believe me ask representative park
cannon the georgia lawmaker who got
arrested just for knocking on the door
of someone who was trying to pass a
voter suppression law
she got charged with a felony
just kidding she got charged with two
can you imagine telling someone marching
in the 60s that we still wouldn't have
this stuff figured out by 2021 they'd be
so disappointed then they'd be like but
you guys have flying cars right and
you'd have to be like oh no but we have
automatic sinks but they don't recognize
black people sorry the future is bad
the filibuster is keeping black
americans from having full voting rights
and it's keeping all americans from
being safe from gun violence and frankly
the word itself sounds very stupid
democrats should get rid of it or at
least make senators see how long they
can talk without letting the n-word slip
out now ever since the election there's
been a lot of talk in the media online
and maybe even in your white family's
group chat about how it's a time to
reach out to republicans who are upset
about the election about how it's
important to build bridges to trump
supporters and to find common ground
with them and i just wanted to let each
and every person out there know that you
100 absolutely do not have to do that
in all honesty i would suggest you don't
and here's why trump supporters are
racist and if you create a space for
racists to thrive they will and is that
something you want truly can cindy come
over to your house and be like yuck
mexicans because if so you are providing
a safe place for her racism to flourish
don't be like that
giving a racist your time and energy is
like giving a seed water and light it
helps them grow into a flower but not a
normal flower one of those terrifying
flowers from little shop of [ __ ]
you don't owe them anything especially
forgiveness because it's okay if you
don't forgive them for what they've done
separating families empowering white
supremacists
bringing back kid rock
your sympathy and empathy are important
and necessary gifts but you don't have
to give those gifts away at the expense
of your humanity
it is not a white elephant party with
your office it's a red elephant party
and all of their gifts are bad and hate
black people so if you needed someone to
tell you this here goes
you do not have to go to their weddings
and you do not have to invite them to
yours your uncle isn't weird weird
uncles have eye patches and tell ghost
stories your uncle is a racist and if he
has an eye patch you have a weird uncle
who is also a racist and whenever we can
have thanksgiving together again you
don't have to go and if you do go you
can tell everybody that uncle patchy
ain't [ __ ] now to be clear i'm not
saying anything radical i'm not saying
burn it down
yet
but really i'm not saying cuss everyone
out i'm just saying you don't have to be
sweet to everyone kindness is your gift
to dole out as you see fit and i really
want you to hear this
searching for the good in someone who
thinks nothing of you is how they
condition us to become accustomed to
being treated like [ __ ]
don't become accustomed to being treated
like [ __ ]
you don't have to be nice to trump
supporters you don't have to find ways
to get close to them in fact you
shouldn't get close to them because
they're probably not wearing a mask
they deserve to lose and they lost and
they're allowed to be sad but you're
allowed to laugh at them because after
all the things they did to us
this [ __ ] is funny as hell recently a
school in michigan had a meeting with
parents to address problems they've been
having with racism in their school
district and in the middle of that
meeting while a father was talking about
his son this happened i remember
when i
went to his bedroom to say good night
and he was crying
because of the abuse that he was
enduring in this school system then why
didn't you stay in mexico
yes she did you need to leave play it
again that's right lady we don't
completely get to see you are the ally
of the week take that you got my order
wrong energy and punish this dizzy [ __ ]
with his hands up like i didn't know we
weren't doing racist [ __ ] today how does
it feel to be hilariously
kindly and completely destroyed by
someone who i'm assuming is the size of
a p
you don't have to be a superhero to be
an ally you can just be a person who's
had enough and also a soprano the anger
that rose up in that lady's chest when
she told your raggedy behind what was
what really is a shining example of what
an ally can be i have watched that video
20 times and tonight after the show i'ma
go home and watch it 20 more in fact i'm
gonna watch it again right now
you almost never get to see a racist out
in the cold light of day loud and wrong
get ripped to stress by an entire
community it was beautiful and it would
not have been possible without the ally
of the week so wherever you are whoever
you are
we salute you now technology exists to
make our lives better but sometimes
things that are there to make life
easier actually make some people's lives
a lot harder the problems can show up in
tiny annoying ways like this story about
automatic soap dispensers that don't
recognize black hands that's right think
of automatic soap dispensers like the tv
show friends they're clean they're
everywhere and they're totally unaware
that black people exist
but here's the thing when it comes to
technology and black people it's not
just our hands that are getting done
dirty first let's talk about something
called artificial intelligence or ai
that's basically when computers are
programmed to do things that usually
take human brains it's how you get
personalized shopping recommendations on
instagram or why google maps can tell
you how to avoid traffic or why anyone
who named their daughter alexa is going
to be apologizing for the rest of their
life
alexa i'm sorry alexa shut up not you
alexa no no alexa i'm gonna kill you not
you alexa you alexa die live alexa
now
we like to think that computers are
neutral but the fact is ai is programmed
by people and people are biased bias is
part of the human condition like love or
death or having to whisper ready tidy
lefty loosey every time you open a jar
but
that bias has real world consequences
take google you know the place where you
search your ex-boyfriend's name six
times a day even though you know you can
do better because that idiot only owns
one towel
in 2015 a black software developer named
jackie alcine realized that when google
photos used ai to categorize his
pictures they sorted images of him and
his black friend into a folder titled
gorillaz
which is insanely racist in fact it's so
racist i give it six months before that
algorithm gets its own fox news show
google's
racist ai isn't just a one-time thing in
one experiment it labeled a thermometer
held by a white hand as an electronic
device and the same object held by a
dark-skinned hand as a gun
which is unacceptable because in this
country the only people allowed to
confuse random objects for guns are the
police officers
but algorithms that label pictures are
just the tip of an extremely racist
iceberg there's also an arbitrary face
scanning algorithm that claims it can
use ai to find out who is best for a job
by scanning their face there's an
algorithm that claims to predict which
criminals will reoffend that has been
known to falsely flag black defendants
as future criminals at almost twice the
rate as white defendants now there's a
medical algorithm that favors white
patients over sick or black ones which
is unforgivable in a system that already
treats black people like an afterthought
unfortunately in america getting
appropriate healthcare is a lot like
playing chess when you're white you
always get to go first that's why my
strategy and either one is to just yell
king me and see if i get anything extra
but as bad as all those other examples
are perhaps the most alarming use of ai
involves facial recognition technology
recently a black computer scientist
named joy blamwini found out that she
couldn't get the robots she worked with
to detect her face she couldn't figure
out why until halloween when she wore a
white mask that's when the robots
immediately recognized her as a person
let me repeat that a black woman
literally wasn't recognized as a human
being unless she wore a white mask a
metaphor so on the nose it's basically a
nostril
it's less a metaphor and more a solid
ending for a jordan peel movie
and by the way the only person who
should have to wear a white mask to get
attention is this guy
we get it phantom you love your love
language is chandeliers and attempted
murder
but
joy's isn't the worst facial recognition
story because if there's anything
scarier than having algorithms ignore
you it's having them do exactly the
opposite just last year a man named
robert williams was arrested for
stealing five watches because facial
rage facial recognition technology
decided his id matched a photo of the
thief there's just one teensy thing
though it was not him in the photo in
fact he had an alibi and even the
detectives admitted the picture wasn't
him but that didn't stop him from having
to pay bond find an attorney and go to
court and the thing is mr williams isn't
alone according to a federal study on
facial recognition asian and
african-american people were up to 100
times more likely to be misidentified
than white people which is insane at
this point you can't even call it facial
recognition anymore it's just
a ridiculously expensive machine that
tells you if someone has a face
so the real question here is what's
causing these racist algorithms and how
do we fix it well let me say it again
computers are programmed by people and
people are biased not just white people
everyone i know i am for example i think
that any couple that rides a tandem
bicycle is definitely plotting each
other's murder
that's a bias i have and i'm not afraid
to admit it but in the case of an ai
in but in the case of ai everyday biases
have life-changing consequences
basically the [ __ ] we put into our
computers is the [ __ ] that comes out
like they used to say in church garbage
in garbage out can the church say amen
haha you're a church so
that means we need diverse faces
training the ai and diverse brains
building it and if women and people of
color aren't included in the ai process
the technology will continue to exclude
us or even worse target us and we can't
let that happen because unless you're a
ghost haunting an opera house this
should never have to be part of your
work uniform texas lieutenant governor
dan patrick vowed to end tenure for
public university professors who teach
critical race theory in their classrooms
he tweeted we banded in publicly funded
k-12 and we will ban it in publicly
funded higher ed
that is just one of the most recent
examples of white americans refusal to
educate students about the advantages of
being white in this country well
if they won't let schools teach that
lesson then i guess i'll have to teach
it right here right now in a little
segment called the
abcs of white privilege
[Music]
there's a lot to learn so let's get
started a is for assimilation
assimilation is when people of color
have to adjust natural things about
themselves to make white people
comfortable this includes code switching
straightening our hair and saying the
beatles are good i'm sorry they stink
and they're not cute
b
is for band-aids being nude and not just
band-aids did you know that until
recently black dancers couldn't find
tights or ballet shoes that match their
skin tone the only options available to
them were nude but who's nude is that
that's not what i look like naked i look
like this
[Applause]
c is for colonization europeans came to
north america and stole this land from
indigenous people but we've been taught
that europeans were brave explorers when
the only thing they actually discovered
was syphilis
wow that that was great i think the
audience learned a lot d is for the doll
test
oh
there's more there is more tarik
the doll test
in the 1940s doctors kenneth and mamie
clark conducted a test in which black
children were presented with dolls of
different colors their studies showed
that most children attributed positive
characteristics to white dolls because
of societal perceptions sad right but if
you ask me barbie wishes she was as fly
as christy
e is for emotional tax now they should
call that [ __ ] physical tax because i
have broken my back dragging white
people into the light and i'm sick of it
it takes its toll emotionally oh that's
where it comes from f is for being
followed around stores i'm looking at
you walgreens
g is for gerrymandering the act of
manipulating congressional boundaries in
favor of a specific political party
otherwise known as racist tetris oh wow
you really did the whole alphabet h is
for something we can't get good health
care black women are three to four times
more likely to die from
pregnancy-related causes than white
women just because they're black and
that's just pregnancies you know they're
everything else
i is for implicit bias now that's when
we attribute stereotypes without our
conscious knowledge here's an example
crossing the street when you see a black
eye but not when you see a white guy
even though both men can and will kill
you dead and that's an implicit bias i
have about men hey
you uh
you know the show is only 22 minutes
long right j is for justice for all
all white people the aclu found that
black people were 3.7 times more likely
to be arrested for marijuana possession
than white people even though their rate
of marijuana usage was comparable they
say justice is for everyone but it's
really just for white people like spf
90.
we really got to speed this up okay fine
buckle up k is for karen duh l is for
laws white people's fubu written for us
by us m is for microaggressions examples
include calling anything ghetto asking
us if we work here or is that your real
hair the receipt said it's mine back up
n is for nano aggressions which are just
itty bitty micro aggressions o is for
oppression which is also the name of
mitch mcconnell's cologne
oppression for men available at walmart
next to the guns
p is for police brutality which we all
know disproportionately affects people
of color you know what else
disproportionately affects people of
color juveniles back that ass up it's
like black people's sweet caroline no no
no no we do not have time for this fine
[Music]
q is for being qualified but underpaid
and underemployed r is for reparations
we've asked for them in every way
possible even venmo run me my check am i
mu we didn't forget about the mule i'm
gonna name mine dante
s is for a savior complex when white
allies feel like they are god's gift to
black people when we all know god's real
gift to black people is rhythm
no
no
no
okay fine
t is for tokenism that's the idea that
you can only have one model minority in
a group of white people now this
practice is used to pit minority groups
against each other for in an effort for
them to excel in white spaces this is
not to be confused with tokenism because
there are no minorities in any lord of
the rings movies at all amber
okay
uvw
therefore upholding values of whiteness
the idea that white is always right is
ingrained into the fabric of this
country when in reality the only thing
that is always right is the price and 90
degree angles x is for xenophobia y is
for why aren't we teaching this in
schools why is this country so afraid to
learn from its racist past and progress
into a future where diversity equity and
inclusion are the understood norm and z
is for zebra yay we read it
[Applause]
now see
that wasn't so bad wasn't terry
oh
well
i guess we don't know when tarik will be
back but we do know
the
abcs of white privilege tonight we're
going to talk about prosecutors you
probably know them from shows like law
and order or the good wife or fancy
justice lady who can really put off pull
off a hat
okay i made up that last one or maybe
i'm here from the future to tell you
about your new favorite show starring
amber ruffin in a hat
prosecutors are so important they even
have their own signature sound
[Music]
you know it that's actually the noise
prosecutors make when they orgasm
scientific fact but here's the thing
that is also one of the whitest sounds
of all time because it turns out that as
of 2019 95 of prosecutors were white and
man 95 is so white it's like i'd like to
speak to the miniature white 95 percent
is front row seats at a billy joel
concert white
america's prosecutors are so white they
think el debarge is a giant mexican boat
and the racial disparity exists all over
the country but hey why does it matter
lots of things are super white and don't
really hurt anyone like living in
vermont or saying i'll be there in a
jiffy
how long is a jiffy white people i need
a number
so let's talk about why the race of
prosecutors matters in three parts first
arrests then charges and finally
sentencing we'll start with the rest now
i know what you're thinking aren't cops
the ones in charge of arresting people
well sort of see there's no point in
arresting someone if they're not going
to be charged with a crime and
prosecutors have basically absolute
power in deciding whether a person gets
criminally charged that's right
prosecutors have the ability to ruin
lives in a split second like plane
crashes or the cool ranch doritos locos
taco supreme combo at taco bell
but i'm still eating that mug
and there are times when prosecutors
choose not to press charges when they
clearly should for example police wanted
to arrest the three men who chased and
murdered a mod arbory but the local d.a
jackie johnson wouldn't allow it then
the case was transferred to this
prosecutor who said there were no
grounds for arrest then they gave the
case to a third white prosecutor who
still didn't arrest anybody it wasn't
until cell phone video of the murder was
released that the state appointed this
woman to the job and she finally charged
ahmad arbury's killers basically those
white prosecutors treated actual
murderers the same way you might treat a
dog who pooped on your living room rug
cover it up pretend it never happened
and hope that someone eventually comes
along and cleans it up for you
since then the three killers have been
convicted by two separate juries and as
for whether the prosecutor's office was
actually racist it is worth noting that
the first d.a actually refused to
prosecute the murderers because one of
them had worked with her in the
prosecutor's office that's right the man
who was just convicted of a federal hate
crime worked for decades in the office
of the district attorney so just like in
scream the call was coming from inside
the house
but arrests aren't the only place where
race plays a role because once you're in
custody prosecutors also get to decide
what crimes you're going to be charged
with and that can be biased as well
a harvard study found that da's charged
black suspects with crimes that carry
worse penalties they ask for higher bail
for black defendants they're less likely
to offer black people plea bargains and
they ask judges to sentence black
defendants to longer terms in prison
in every single possible way black
people face worse outcomes than white
people which is the opposite of what
happens during a line dance
i love it
and even if somehow you are fairly
arrested and charged racism can also
play a role in sentencing now i know you
think i'm going to give you a bunch of
stats about how judges and juries give
longer sentences to black people and
that's true but it's not the most
important thing because over 90 of
felony convictions are actually the
result of plea deals and the terms of
those deals are offered by you guessed
it the prosecutors
oh good for them they met someone
a recent new york city study showed that
black defendants were more likely than
whites to be offered plea deals that
included jail or prison time and it's
not just true in new york take these to
ohio women who are convicted of
embezzlement carla hopkins and debbie
bosworth now first yes debbie bosworth
sounds exactly like the name i would
make up for that white lady but it's
also her actual name
now carla stole 42 000 while debbie on
the other hand stole almost a quarter of
a million and carla was sentenced to 18
months in prison while debbie was given
just 10 months just kidding six just
kidding zero she was given zero prison
time fear these are two women in the
same county in the same court system who
were sentenced within one year of one
another
i wonder what could have made the
difference
basically
think of making a fair plea deal like
singing along to a jimmy buffett song
anyone can do it but it's going to go a
whole lot better if you're white
it's not applicable to me and
margaritaville
is that jimmy buffett uh
i don't know that's fair you shouldn't
now
i know i've spent all this time telling
you about problems with white
prosecutors and to be fair we don't know
for sure that black prosecutors would
fix the criminal justice system we only
know that in studies black judges showed
less of a bias against black defendants
that black cops are less likely to use
force and that juries with at least one
black member are less likely to convict
a black suspect
does that mean that black prosecutors
will do a better job dealing with racial
disparities how the hell would i know
because here's the thing there aren't
enough of them to count but we need to
find out because the next time i hear
this
i only want to be thinking about one
thing
sweet lovemaking
recently marvel comics introduced a new
character named princess matoka now if
that sounds familiar it's because matoka
is the birth name of an indigenous woman
most of us know as pocahontas now i know
what you're thinking what a great
opportunity to show a historic native
woman for the complicated resourceful
brave person that she was well instead
they did this
wow yeah first that's super racist
second it's very confusing to literally
anyone who has seen a woman in her
underwear
now in case you're wondering if this was
drawn by a man let me point out that
there are zero bra straps and she's
wearing gold pasties and yeah she's
holding up a metal orb entirely with the
strength of her breasts
apparently this comic is set in an
alternate universe where native women
exist but gravity does not
now if it's not clear to you why that
character is upsetting people let's take
a minute and decolonize your
understanding
native women have been hyper-sexualized
throughout american history and the
consequences have been devastating
according to the department of justice
native american women are two to three
times more likely than women of any
other race to experience violence
stalking or sexual assault and that is
terrifying the only thing native women
should experience three times more than
other races is compliments about their
incredible community and nation-building
skills then
good job good job
now instead of focusing on this
offensive depiction of matoka let's
learn about the reality now many of you
are probably familiar with her mostly
from disney's pocahontas a movie about a
native woman who falls in love with an
english guy named john smith saves his
life has a close personal friendship
with a raccoon
of course almost none of that turns out
to be true i mean i'm not ruling out the
raccoon part they're adorable and they
seem like great listeners i don't know
who her friends were but in reality
matuka was around 10 years old when she
met john smith and he was almost 30 so
instead of this it would have looked a
bit more like this
so
unlike the disney movie there was never
any kind of romance between mathoka and
john smith because and this is important
ew
also in every portrait of john smith he
has this facial hair and whether it's
the 1600s or 2022 i think we all would
have clocked that mustache as something
you don't let around young children
so
disney was wrong about the romance and
the age although that's definitely not
disney's biggest age-related lie
i'm just gonna say it there's no way
chip is mrs pot's son
here is what she looks like when she
turns back into a human that lady is in
her late 60s easy now you're telling me
she has a kid chips age
what kind of secrets are you hiding in
that teapot mrs potts
the movie also says that matoka snuck
food to john smith and even risked her
own life to stop her tribe from
executing him but it turns out those
parts probably aren't true either first
of all according to the indigenous site
indian country today when the colonists
didn't grow enough food for themselves
john smith actually stole food from the
tribe by holding a gun to the heads of
village leaders so natives like matoka
likely gave john smith food in the same
way that cashier gives all his money to
a gyneski mask
and as for matoka saving john smith from
execution well historians say that
probably didn't happen either in fact
many deny that he was going to be
executed at all
that's right native historians have
called out the lies just like i'm going
to call out anyone who thinks john smith
is hotter than coco
you are wrong and i will fight you
you're you're wrong and i'm going to
fight you john smith looks like if x
body spray was a person
he's the human embodiment of crushing a
beer can on your forehead
he's the third to last guy on every
season of the bachelorette and you know
what else john smith's bangs are the
mcdonald's logo
that's right i said it so why is it that
many of us have learned this incorrect
history well because america likes
stories about native women that make it
look like they welcome western culture
and live happily ever after
the actual story of matuka is a
devastating one according to native
accounts she was kidnapped raped by
colonists and died before the age of 21.
and no matter how many adorable raccoons
you add that story sucks but it's the
truth so for just a second let's bring
back this picture now the writer
actually apologized for his depiction of
princess matuka and vowed to change the
name and the design after he was called
out on twitter by native comic lovers
but i don't want to focus on the writer
of that comic i do want to talk about
why it matters because continuing to
hyper-sexualize indigenous women in
fiction can lead us to ignore their
abuse in real life according to a 2016
report from the national institute of
justice more than four out of five
indigenous women reported they had been
the victim of violence and 96 of them
described their attacker as non-native
american
even worse those attackers often can't
be prosecuted that's because the 1978
supreme court case called olefant versus
sukhwamish indian tribe decided tribes
have limited authority to prosecute
non-tribal citizens that leaves open
a legal loophole where in some cases
non-natives can enter a reservation
commit violence and not be held
responsible which is insane it's like if
i went to florida and kicked a bunch of
people in the shins and then i got away
with it because i don't live in florida
that's not right i should be held
accountable or i'll just keep kicking
poor tarik now here's the thing
we as artists and consumers have to be
extra careful in how we treat native
people because our country has not been
theorefen show was filmed on the
traditional land of the lenape people's
past and present and we honor with
gratitude the land itself and the people
who have stewarded it throughout the
generations it is our duty
it's our duty to make sure indigenous
women are depicted with care and
integrity and more importantly make sure
they get a chance to depict themselves
that means supporting native women in
everything from writers rooms to rooms
it means donating to the national
indigenous women's resource center it
means supporting positive native
representation by watching shows like
reservation dogs and rutherford falls
and speaking of support it also means
making damn sure they get all the bra
straps they need
[Music]
[Applause]
you